In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading, from the Sinaxadion for June 11, on which we commemorate the two hundred
and twenty-two new martyrs of the Russian mission in Peking.
In 1900, the Secret Society of Martial Arts, the Boxers, supported by the Dowager Empress
who was known for Herzinophobia, began a persecution of the Christians, whom they held responsible
for all the ills that were afflicting China.
On the 10th of June, proclamations were posted in the streets of Peking, calling on the pagans
to massacre the Christians and threatening anyone who dared to conceal them.
The following night, the Boxers, passing through every quarter with flaming torches, arrested
all the Orthodox Christians they found in their houses, and tortured them to make them
deny Christ.
Many of them, terrified by the tortures, burned incense before the idols to save their
lives, while others courageously confessed their faith and endured terrible torments.
After having burned down their houses, the Boxers took them outside the town to their
pagan temples, where the Christians were eviscerated, beheaded, or burned to death.
All one, an Orthodox catechist, died with a prayer on his lips.
Yah, when, a teacher at the Russian mission, was twice tortured and joyously confessed
Christ, John, an eight-year-old child, had his arms cut off, and his chest slashed.
When the executioners asked him if it was hurting, he answered with a smile.
It is not difficult to suffer for Christ.
The Boxers beheaded him and burned his remains on a bonfire.
Father Metrophonies C. Chung, the first Chinese priest, who had been ordained by St. Nicholas
of Japan, and had untiringly served the mission for fifteen years, was killed, long with seventy
Christian men, women, and children who had taken refuge with him after the buildings
of the Russian mission were burned down.
When the Boxers went in, they found him sitting in the courtyard, and pierced him all over
with dagger-thrusts in the chest.
His wife Tatiana was beheaded, as well as his twenty-three-year-old son, Isaiah.
His other son, aged seven, had his toes, nose, and ears cut off while his father was
being martyred.
He felt no pain, however, and while his torturers were calling him son of demons, he replied,
I am a believer in God, and not a disciple of demons.
Isaiah's fiance, Maria, aged nineteen, went to Father Metrophonies' house, wanting to
die with her fiance's family.
When the Boxers left the house, she helped the survivors to save themselves by climbing
the wall, then turned to face her assailants, accusing them of slaughtering innocent people
without trial.
Not daring to kill her, they wounded her arms, and put nails through her feet.
When she was pressed to flee, she replied, I was born near the church of the most holy mother
of God, and it is here that I shall die.
When the Boxers returned, they killed her.
Among the blessed martyrs there were also descendants of the people of Alba-Zin in Russia, who
had brought the light of Christ to Peking in 1685.
Clement Kui-Kin, Matthew Heitzwan, his brother Vetus, and Chui, and a number of others, not
fearing those who killed the body, but are not able to kill the soul.
Courageously went to meet torture and death, praying to the Lord to enlighten their persecutors,
and forgive their sins.
Of the thousand souls who made up the Russian mission in Peking, it lost 300 in these bloody
events, 222 of whom received the incorruptible crown of martyrdom.
Through the prayers of our holy fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God, have mercy on us
and save us.